love talking to this guy love our
conversations his podcast green light
with chris long is available we're all
podcasts are acquired the the man uh
himself is on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line here on the rich eisen show
chris long back here how are you sir
rich what's up i'm just uh just taking
in that that game are you watching the
manning cast you watching that manning
cast dude you know what uh actually last
night i stepped away from football for a
few so how dare you see
the throws you were talking about in the
second half but i kind of had the sound
off you know i got a sports pop culture
kind of podcast so when i'm i'm kind of
tired of the sports i can do pop culture
okay so you know so you have not seen
the manning cast just yet no you know i
actually was in their mock um their mock
broadcast like you hit me up and i was
very flattered that they wanted to use
me for practice
uh
which is like maybe i should be
flattered by but you know maybe we'll
see if they call me to come on the real
thing so it's you're like pre-season is
what you're saying and now it's
essentially like one of the last
preseason games you know these shows
they're big productions so they have to
like practice and
they needed you know a practice squad
guy so to speak
to come on and do like the fourth
quarter of some blowout but i gotta tell
you like and i mean this sincerely
i did you know usually i come onto my
show
you can get carried away enjoy talking
to him
but
i i didn't want to leave the show
because i just wanted to listen to them
talk football the whole night you know
like
that i think is the appeal
of having that format if two guys really
know the game and could be
conversational and casual that's how i'd
rather watch a game
than the traditional you know um color
commentary play-by-play kind of triangle
offense with somebody on the sideline i
like the demanding cast better
well they last night uh in the first
quarter immediately identified how the
lions defensively were trying to slow
aaron rodgers down and dare him to throw
into the
the two deep safeties and it was just
fascinating just watching it play out
and you know they'd comment about how a
safety came up late and what that means
for rogers and rogers is noticing it and
the floor is definitely noticing it and
he's giving him two plays right now and
roger's like they walked us through what
how how everyone was was absorbing the
real-time action and chess maneuvering
and it was fascinating just absolutely
fascinating and then uh then uh payton
dropped at one point that he was
concerned being in the visitors locker
room in new england that there there
could be a hot mic in there
then you know we walked through uh
fake plays before the uh the super bowl
against them when we were with the
eagles and i didn't like you know i've
been in new england i've never seen him
do anything shady you know i think it's
just become like pop culture at this
point but um yeah we walked through a
couple fake plays that we weren't going
to run at all just in case someone was
watching that's what you said dude yeah
i mean this is i'm not the first one to
to say this publicly but
um yeah it's folklore at this point
the height of paranoia so doug
peterson's like we're we're not doing
this but let's do it we ran like some
like these trick plays and i turned to
fletch and i was like man
these look cool and he's like yeah
they're not real plays
but then what the philly special was i
mean really special was one we did not
run i don't think because uh for that
very reason well didn't you tell me like
philly special there was no dress
rehearsal that i know of well the idea
was again if i'm not mistaken the philly
special was something that you had
planned for the nfc championship game
just didn't have an opportunity i have
no idea listen like here's the problem i
i say anything about the eagles and i
end up on like uh nbc sports uh
philadelphia like clickbait journalism
washing machine situation so i'm gonna
let's move away from the eagles i took
us here well you know what i'll no no
it's it's it's all good i mean because
it's just uh
funny how the manning cast can just go
all over the place is my point to begin
with
rich i think the one thing that that's
missing from a lot of broadcast yes like
you know i'm being dead serious is like
linemen who who know or somebody in
these quarterbacks ears
collectively like on their little
headset feeding them the right
terminology for how to talk about line
play and what's going on up front and i
think like any linemen that are
listening right now to your show or
watching it probably not in their heads
like there are times where we feel very
underrepresented so
what like like how like walk me through
that chris long terminology you know
guys won't know what you know what it
how to term a twist done or a game or
the difference between you know what to
call an inside move uh butchering kind
of like shock and shed terminology like
the basics um also not knowing like hey
when a when a rusher wins at 11 yards
maybe it wasn't a great rush you know
maybe the quarterback drifted to 11 and
it's his fault
little nuances like that
they just kind of gloss right over him
because
the typical fan i mean his ball watching
so we got to get you on the manning cast
then i mean you're hoping so i mean i
mean you'll get called up i think you'll
get called up
listen i want the cats out of the bag i
guess i'm going to be on the manning
cast they call back
the active roster and i think at some
point this year i'm supposed to be
honest i would you know what i would do
i would do a long cast i would watch a
long cast i'd watch you i'm serious i'd
watch you and your brother and your dad
you know i mean it's i would watch one
of those would you do something like
that chris uh you might watch it but i i
talk to them plenty of a live stream
dude so
i think we're good on that you know i'm
not i'm sure peyton and eli connect you
know i mean so you're right you're right
i would love to because you're you know
like like let's see what we can do here
i i would watch something like that
maybe we can live stream the next jets
game or something that'll be fun
you want me in on that because you
better
you better understand it's working blue
my guys my guys around here want me to
work blue in the worst way you know and
stuart and stuart scott and i whenever
he used to do a sports center we would
just work blue off camera and would say
this should be like a pay-per-view like
a sports center pay-per-view where we
work blue i would have paid you know
oh my gosh chris long here uh on the on
the rich eisen show so when you see
brady doing what he's doing right now
nine touchdowns and gronk
getting four of them i mean it's it's
it's insane it really i i don't i don't
there's really no
words for it but i do want to put it in
your lap here somebody's played with him
and knows what it takes to prepare for
an nfl season physically mentally and
the fact he's 44 and doing this it's it
does not compute chris yeah it's crazy i
think in the scary thing is the bucks
are kind of because they played in that
that spot with atlanta sandwiched in
between like so many good games that
were objectively like interesting and
compelling like i don't think a lot of
people watched them last week other than
like red zone so
you know no offense to tampa fans i mean
they've kind of
gotten pretty quickly uh into this
boring good mode um
you know last year they they peak late
they win a super bowl um and you think
like super bowl hangover maybe a little
rust i've said this before i think a lot
of people made a little bit too big of a
deal of the bill and tom head to head
kind of you know narrative last year
because
i just didn't think that would be the
barometer for like you know what came
first the chicken or the egg up in new
england i actually think there's an
interesting thread that people are
missing this year which is like tom's
brilliance when it comes to setting the
top the tone you know setting the
temperature in the locker room after a
super bowl run like that that had to be
exhausting you know with all things
considered in the the pandemic and all
that
this is even tougher to rebound from an
effort like that like so tom brady being
able to get this team back into kind of
like tip top shape focused energized
playing good out of the gate like that's
new england stuff that's like bill
belichick stuff so i thought this year
the true test for tom as a leader which
is almost a bit unfair but he's played
himself and led himself into this
echelon of people we can talk about this
way like this is the mark of the goat
like
as much as anything how you get a team
to rebound after super bowl effort and
play like that super bowl team out of
the gate that rarely happens we know
that
so that's a check mark in toms uh in
tom's column when you talk about him and
bill
he's at least part of why they were
perpetually good at that in new england
no there's no question about that there
there is no doubt that that that's woven
in his dna and that's what made the
brady belichick relationship work for
israel
rich is
you know as many as they won there and
then doing them sometimes you know
early on like clustered together um and
then you know later that long that long
break but still being able to after
disappointing runs that might end in the
end of the afc championship or in the
super bowl like they were able to pick
themselves off the mat and and play good
football immediately the next year it's
hard to stay that way i mean i've been
on like you know teams that that were
that way and then you know fell off you
know i i i i
you forget that you know belichick and
brady
lasted 20 years that is an in that is
unheard of marriage we will never get
100 years in human honestly like andy
reed and mahomes are gonna have to be
attached at the hip together another 15
years to match it yep from here from
this moment it's fun in new england
though you know i do think and this
isn't taking
anything away from bill and tom's
relationship for that run
it was excellent in its own way but i
like seeing like a scrappy
resourceful bill you know he's always
resourceful but
um i think it's really fun to see this
chapter they've never had a quarterback
and i know tom always took a haircut but
like you've got mac jones on a rookie
deal and if he's the guy that that means
you know you like seeing new faces in
new england like you know the nelson
aguilars of the world the world that the
judons of the world like fun faces that
are going to pop up up there and and
bill's going to spend and they're going
to look differently they're going to
have to win differently i think this is
fun like i've never wanted to watch the
pats more
you know and it is interesting also to
watch what belichick is doing with mac
jones you know where
where where jones had the game that
robert sala wanted his kid and zach
wilson have saying it's good to play
boring i mean mac jones
his stat line was boring and then yeah
you know and then you heard from
belichick afterwards and they asked him
what you think about mac jones and he
did his usual
response that was boring and boring
wins in the nfl if you don't make
mistakes and just seeing belichick get
this kid up to speed so fast
uh in a way that obviously trevor
lawrence and zach wilson still looking
for a w and justin fields is still kind
of nailed to the bench there the injury
and the dalton might change that i'm
just i'm fascinated to see how belichick
is operating in in his 2.0 right exactly
and so like you know you're watching
those games and you know mac jones might
be boring at this point
but if you appreciate bill there's
always some storyline there's always
some angle there's like who are they
going to come out and try to be this
week
and you know brady could oftentimes
overshadow that and his gr his greatness
so like
to to give bill the floor a little bit
so to speak and say like okay now we can
really appreciate the resourcefulness
with which he coaches and so you know
the gm thing has been the biggest strike
against his kind of legacy
um
i've been excited to watch a lot of
these new faces in in new england this
year and he's going to get an honest
second crack at it with a rookie
quarterback on a rookie deal the next
couple chris long here on the rich eisen
show is green light podcast for all
podcasts are available and just one last
one on this is i do enjoy though seeing
brady post belichick not football but
just personality wise i mean the tommy
gronky videos that they're doing even
though he's dead serious and getting
this team
focused on another super bowl and it
appears that they are like lockstep
they're having fun with videos i don't
know if you saw brady's uh you know each
week he's now as you know for a couple
of years he's been doing these hype
videos on his social media i don't know
if you saw the one prior to the falcons
they're impeccable dude well i mean the
one prior to the falcons he did it in
front of a screensaver in front of a
computer that the timestamp on it was
328
because he's taking on the falcons and
the score was 28 to 3. yeah he's got
like all these easter eggs and stuff for
people to find like
which goes to show you like tom's
creative but he's got a a solid team
he doesn't have time to do all this
stuff but i guess my question for you is
is this the brady that you knew when you
played with like because we didn't see a
lot of this stuff you know i don't want
to be the the window into tom brady for
the world because that would be uh
that wouldn't like he had better friends
than me on that team right by far
obviously goes out saying i mean but
i liked him and i thought he was fun and
i thought he was easy going and a you
know a good teammate so
you know when you're up in new england
you know the building has no windows
that's not to say it's bad thing but you
know
what what happens there stays there and
i think they'll be like the island uh in
a changing nfl landscape where
you know everybody else is you know each
each player you know their brand
particularly well
um but i thought
you know bill let can be cam too so
i think sometimes it's kind of over
played you know the the new england is a
vault thing i i just think you know tom
has grown through years where bill was
learning to let players be players and
now tom's in tampa and that's kind of is
what it is now and he can be who he is
chris long here on the rich eisen show
so i guess uh my last one for you would
be uh which team do you believe has the
best chance to dethrone the bucks who
look like they're they have totally
picked up where they left off
brady it's no longer a transition year
like it's now a routine year he's in his
routine now so what what happens from
here on out is to your best crystal ball
ability chris long do you think well i
have uh the chiefs beating the rams that
that was my super bowl right there you
know a little bit of a homer pick
because my brother's there i didn't
expect that the the defense would come
out looking like this and i actually
think it's funny i joked the other night
that like
kansas city's defense is good for the
nfl like
it makes the nfl less boring you know
like we
we get tired of seeing kansas city trot
out there and and and teams play catch
up to no avail every week
now we're going to see some barn burners
i mean we've seen two to start the
season so
um and then la my biggest concern
probably
is that situation a running back
you know you've had two injuries now
that you've sustained and i don't know
how serious
uh the the second injury is but um you
know they look really good in fact um
matt stafford and cooper cup are like
best buddies like hot seat for clayton
kershaw like they've just
they've just literally
picked up
right where they left off and better and
you know as a sidebar there
jared goff not looking half bad for a
while last night you know i think
everybody can win in the nfl at times
because i i think it was a situation
there in la
where that relationship the relationship
had soured between the quarterback and
coach
chris i love the chats man always uh
i'll i'll throw you one curveball at the
end here because i know you interviewed
him recently jj reddick hung it up after
15 years says it's time to be a dad i
guess i assume you know him and know him
well and dad
chelsea chelsea boots leather bound
books he's a brooklyn guy he's
he's just gonna he's gonna become even
more of a hipster
and uh listen i love jj from a little
bit i've gotten to know him right he
seems like a great dude really humble
for a guy that kind of was iconic for a
period not just in college basketball
but one of the best shooters in the nba
has ever seen so like anybody ever
talked to a great teammate and his
podcast is awesome so shout out to jj uh
and tommy old man of three
chris long you're the best uh thanks for
the call best your family uh yes sir you
know the long cast i don't need 10
percent don't worry
just go ahead and do it um that would
involve us all getting on on the phone
at the same time and working our
technologies respectively so i don't
think it's going to happen
are you saying hold on are you saying
your dad's the weakest link on that
that's the weakest link but not by much
i mean i feel like a legitimately 55
year old man um so uh you know dad i had
him in a fantasy football league the
other night he had to auto pick two two
players because he couldn't get into the
website there
he got he got austin eclair though so
you know what i went to i lost to a week
one to a guy who auto picked and he had
austin eckler so
it all works out i guess in the long run
so my gosh it always does take care of
yourself chris look for my call
look for my call please do that's chris
long everybody right here green light
with chris long where all podcasts are
acquired
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here